there's this misconception that troubles
problems crisis danger once you solve
them they go away but the truth of the
matter is that crisis is never ending
it's never going away and once you
figure out a way how to handle it you'll
position yourself to have major
opportunities come your way in this
video we're gonna talk about the
following different forms of crisis life
span of a crisis what extends the life
span of a crisis and last but not least
rules of engagement when it comes out to
crisis make sure you stay tuned to the
varying because I got a surprise I want
to share with you but let me get right
into so two forms of crisis crisis gonna
happen all the time but there's two
forms of it the types you can control
the kind you cannot control
unfortunately most people spend way too
much time trying to solve crises that
they don't have any controller but the
crisis that you do have control over you
ought to put some energy into it so what
kind of forms of crisis do we have
number one is health you're building a
business some happens to your health
you're affected setback
takes you time to regain that momentum
sometimes you lose momentum that is one
form of crisis the other one is
technological and cyber when I say
technological if you have a technology a
software that use that all of a sudden
it collapses or you know information
that's being a leak or there's a cyber
attack on your technology somebody gets
into it there's a virus that is a very
massive for some companies if this
happens for them it is a form of crisis
Nexus organizational organizational when
there's a falling out or a mismanagement
of a crisis that happens with somebody
that doesn't work out whether they leave
or whether there's somebody that doesn't
replace someone that needs to be
replaced because their attitude is
tremendously negative and they're
hurting the morale of the office next
one is violence this happens every once
in a while and sometimes you hear
stories about an office or a company
outside a bank the other day I'm talking
to my guy Joe and I said Joe how are
things he says man did you hear about
what happened yesterday I said no what
happened yesterday he says he's the
first chair when you walk into the bank
he says the other day this guy walks in
and he shows me the gun he comes up and
he says give me all the money you have I
see you gotta be he says take your hand
off the button he
then he goes to the back with his buddy
two guys are holding up he says they
took all our cash they left cops ran off
they still haven't caught this guys you
gotta be gives us know that kind of
violence would gonna puts a lot of fear
in people people are worried because
they have nightmares with guns that is a
different form of crisis that you
experience next one is malice
manipulation deception and revenge
because you may have somebody a
competitor who doesn't like you
defamation of character rumor mill all
over the place you're this you're that
you're going out of business you don't
have money you don't know what you're
doing or one of your guys within the
company doesn't like you have a falling
out they leave their life mission is to
make sure that put the biggest revenge
on you and they're never gonna stop
right those are the things that happen
about the way some of this is caused by
you some of it it's out of your control
but some of these things we're talking
about is in your control we'll get back
to that here in a minute
next one defamation of character which
we talked about briefly financial is the
next one some it's your finances meaning
you didn't save money for rainy day you
spend way too much money you will extend
it yourself the other kind of financial
crisis is the market something happens
to the market and it affects everything
else that you're doing as well eight
black swuan you can't predict it what's
a Black Swan a pandemic a corona virus a
9/11 you cannot predict that and
earthquake is more of a Black Swan than
a hurricane because the hurricane tells
you next Monday at 7:30 p.m. a hurricane
is gonna hit Miami so you're prepared
four or five days until that comes but a
pandemic comes out of nowhere catches us
we're not prepared for it and earthquake
it six point six earthquake in
Northridge Oh a bunch of businesses take
it 9/11 happens to place how did this
take place we're affected by it
that's all so blacks wander you can
predict next one is personal marital
kids wife my wife and I our daughter
goes to class the three-year-old there's
a classmate that she had in that
classroom that three-year-old passed
away in the most troubling way were the
mother and the father don't have an
answer for it and the funeral was a very
emotional funeral my wife was calling me
crying because she said I can't even be
here
I can't imagine experiencing the pain
that the moment that are experiencing
right now my wife is in tears my body
hurts I'll never forget when she made
the phone call so why he telling me this
she says this is what just happened
that's personal man that hurts for a
long time it is a form of crisis right
now last but not least is natural what's
natural natural crisis some of the stuff
you don't control some of the stuff that
happens that is not your fault not my
fault nobody else's how it just kind of
happens these are different forms of
crisis the key whatever you wanted is to
know which one of them you control which
one of them don't health you eat the way
you eat your immune system your diet
exercise routine alcohol drugs
technological cyber are you prepared do
you have the right cybersecurity have
you put that investment into it are you
being too cheap
are you willing to go learn a little
more are you hiring the right analysts
that are going to put the right things
in place we had a test scoring that
we're doing on the cyber that we were
not prepared for it we invested a few
hundred thousand dollars to make sure we
were protected of it because just in
case so some of it is you some of the
organizational same violence sometimes
it's not yours but you need to be
prepared what if it does happen so every
one of these things we need to look at
which one of them you control and which
one you do now these things that we're
looking at it becomes bigger problem
based on the time timeline lifespan of
the crisis so watch this sometimes
crisis lasts one hour some happens to
your boom it's a crisis
what's a crisis one hour flat tire
middle the freeway what do you do okay
that's one out you got to fix a triple-a
all this other stuff right sometimes
you're here at an office something
happens it's one hour how do you handle
that situation some of them are one day
it lasts the whole day some of it is a
week some of it is a month some of it is
a quarter some of it is a year and some
of them last a decade what do you mean a
decade Depression was a decade plus that
ax lasted so what could we have done to
prevent it it the key with this is to
pump it up
meaning if it's supposed to last a week
can you make it last a day if it's
supposed to last a day can you make it
last an hour if it's supposed to last an
hour can you do anything to make it only
be 15 minutes or 10 minutes but most
people unfortunately amateurs it's
supposed to last an hour they make it a
day it's supposed to last a day they
make it last a week it's supposed to
only be a one-week crisis it becomes a
one-month crisis it's supposed to be a
one-month crisis it becomes a one-year
crisis and you know how this thing goes
on so now your strategies to not
the crisis this is what you need be
thinking about your strategies which you
put in place one you have the crisis
that shows up will dictate if it extends
it or shortens it number two your
emotional response to the crisis the way
you carry yourself emotionally like
there's a lot of people I'm talking to
half the time I'm talking to my
employees here we have the office we
send you know 70 of our employees home
and we have 20 them that are working out
of here and oh we have another 10 that's
working out of a different place but
when we send the employee some one of
the things I'm doing just talking to
people how you doing the other day I
held a meeting and kinda thing we have
the video of this meeting so maybe we
put a little bit of a glimpse of it I
held the meeting and I just sat there
and I had all our employees around us
the ones that were here we had already
send them you know pregnant ones home on
some debt their spouses were nurses
where kids were sent home so we wanted
to make sure they had the opportunity to
do that but I just sat there for one
hour and they were all there Aubree
buddy buy their cubicles under this I
said what's on your mind what are you
thinking about what's your biggest fear
what's your biggest concern they asked
me 20 different questions why I'm trying
to show you listen if your seals not
panicking
everything's gonna be all right my wife
last night we're talking babe why are
you not worried I'm not worried baby cuz
it's gonna be all right we're gonna be
okay my dad my mom today hey is
everything okay mom everything's gonna
be all right how you doing how's that
how's everybody Hey investors say what
everything's gonna be all right we're
all right right because somebody brings
the tension down and your emotional
response helps with the lifespan of the
problem number three your approach to
the crisis okay again how you approach
the crisis panic more little tool
Mountain how do you handle it that also
dictates a lifespan of it number four
your level of poise similar I have
people that I work with one of the other
day I was doing a conference call and my
guys were asking me questions about our
leaders that are doing what the ones
that make seven figures and they say
what's the best quality of this person
what's the best quality of that person
what's the best quality this person one
of the guys they asked about his name is
Jose okay very good friend of mine we go
way back with this guy 15 years when I
met him he wanted to work with me I
don't let him come to my office for 90
days I told me how to do certain things
finally he says whatever you tell me I'm
gonna do because I want to work with you
so finally six months later this guy
came into my office we started working
together I would take him to
mónica stairs would be doing stairs late
at night 11:30 you know I take him
everywhere I could to see how tough it
was but boom this guy's like no we're
gonna be working together he was
determined right here's this guy's
biggest strength one day I'm sitting
there and I'm talking to somebody that
wat to do business with he's sitting
over here at my office in Northridge
next thing you know big earthquake hit
six point one 6.2 earthquake kids I had
this massive window in my office
going back and forth the guy we're doing
business with I look this way I look up
boom out of my office he runs out I look
at or say he's just sitting there so
what do you think I said what do you
mean what do you think's earthquake
still movements been 30 seconds I think
we should probably go outside what do
you think Pat I said I think we should
go outside as well we got up and he just
walks eating he always walks like a very
smooth operator this guy's had four
nicknames with me over the years the
first one was Rico suave the number is
second make then what I think was
Seabiscuit the third one was Mexican
John F Kennedy and his nickname today I
tell him it's like the Teflon Don Eazy
you know because he's so calm nothing
bothers him right it's such a powerful
quality he has because people look at
him and boom it gives people strength
with the poise that he has number 5 your
urgency with finding a solution
sometimes people move too slow and then
this goes boom boom boom boom boom boom
boom your urgency something all it's
okay one week problem one month problem
one year problem
can you prop it's not a big deal that
I'm gaining weight it's alright then
boom boom boom now you lost a decade why
because you weren't paying attention to
your health that's a decade problem you
don't think it's that serious then the
last two points both of them are
opposites but it's pretty much the same
thing number six is your exaggeration of
a crisis you turn to three and two a
nine and the last one is your under
exaggeration of a crisis you turn a nine
in two or three it's a very big deal
that's not a big deal
alright you know it's not really a big
deal it's a very big deal we'll see
what's gonna happen it's not really a
big deal there's time to be calm and not
be and there's time to say no the level
of urgency on this is high we got to get
right into it so dough
some of the things that causes the
lifespan of the crisis to be longer now
rules of engagement with crisis I got a
few points for you again this is one of
those things that you can write an
entire book about right you can do an
entire course about you can do an entire
session about I can teach on this for
two or three days but this is a twenty
minute video we're doing here so rules
of engagement number one what caused it
that's what I want to know is it in my
control or out of my control so the
first thing I want to know okay if it's
not in my control I automatically tell
our guys I'm not worried about the other
day we had a crisis that took place with
webinar that we were putting for three
thousand people and last minute it's
only letting us do five hundred so I had
only one thing in mind was it our
mistake
or was it go to webinars mistake so I
had my guy go and find out right there
and we found out that GoToWebinar didn't
do their upgrade to the number that we
needed to but there was one thing we
could have done no part we could have
done something about that person had a
very interesting conversation with me
the part that we didn't have the ability
to have any control of those there's we
got the apology from then saying we're
so sorry we messed up but what is the
moral of the story first part is what is
our control what is outside of our
control number two for exists
coronavirus is it out of your control
yes what part of it's your control
washing your hands preparation and
educational research there's both
aspects to it right
number two quantify the risk of the
crisis meaning worst-case Center I
always go to worst-case in here what's
the or since I've kind of that's gonna
happen here I think we could lose a half
a million dollars okay that's a good
number
we could lose a half a million dollars
what's the worst case to know that can
happen here we can shut down six
operations that we have okay what's the
worst thing that can happen here you
could die
okay what's the worst thing that can
happen so you always go to worst-case
and then you assess it and say okay I
gotta mentally be prepared how bad this
thing could be then you go back to the
normal again number three find the root
cause to eliminate future repetitive
events meaning if I have an issue and I
just put a bandaid on it it's gonna
reappear I'm not interested in that I
want to eliminate the issue so it never
reappears again and we can move on I
don't like the same issues happening
over and over and over again if you ever
ask our directors or board members and
see how is it working what Patti will
tell you
Pat will be very upset and disappointed
if the same issue keeps
appearing but if it happens the first
time he's just like listen let's solve
this so it never happens again
and he's very calm about it I don't like
the same issue happening over and over
and over again so I'll sit down I'll say
what caused this welcome Emma
wondering what do you do we have this
person do we have that person how do we
hire maybe I wouldn't are do we need to
call to them that's what we're doing to
make sure it doesn't happen again number
four battle plan both defense and
offense sometimes you know we only run
like defensively I'm just gonna make
sure this never happens to me again but
what we do is while you're playing
defense you forget that you need to also
make sales to make the company go if you
don't make sense and make money this
company is going out of business so then
sometimes people all they're thinking
about is offense offense often that's
kind of like the boat you know you're
all so it's okay I know we're sinking
but it's all good man just keep playing
offense no no you got to make sure that
thing gets plugged up as well so this
ship is not sinking so we got to make
sure we score that away so if you just
do this and you ain't rowing you staying
put
but if you just do this and you don't
plug the hole you're sinking so you got
to make sure you doing both you don't
just do one out of town number five
unified the team with a unified strategy
that addresses the crisis so one
coronavirus happen immediately I'm
having conversations with everybody
immediately I talk to probably four or
five hundred people in a day immediately
I'm in communication with everybody then
we set up the webinar we then we handle
our issues here then I've addressed it
with my investors then I address it with
my executive team then we announce that
all the employees then we made a
strategy what we're going to be doing
then we had everybody that got to get it
then I want you to see my face not audio
I just want you to see my face because
if you see my face I will see if you're
comfort and I know you're confident and
I know everything's gonna be all right
they're not that gets transferred so if
you're and you're worried you may not
want to show your face because if they
see your face maybe they're gonna be
more worried so for some of you may not
actually be a good strategy but I want
you to see my face then when you see my
face I always open up with a question
what's on your mind
guys what's keeping you up at night
what's on your mind open in tell me
because they're gonna tell you their
fears and concerns what are some of the
challenges you're facing we haven't seen
before and they'll give it to you right
and then I already have a plan of action
that I've mapped out because I've spent
some time talking to myself or board or
whoever it is then I'll say here's the
direction very important to be clear
with the directions you
if what action items here's what we need
to do number one is this number two of
this number three is this number four is
this number five is number six is it if
this happened we're gonna be doing this
if that happens we're gonna be doing
this just so you guys know for some of
you guys that are worried about it if
you're worried about this happen we're
all will be prepared for this if we're
worried about this happen we already
prepare for this but guess what guys
here's what I think we need to do while
everybody else is scared we need to go
up and play offense defense offense goes
back to the same message I give to you
earlier number six best time for crisis
to get your relationships deeper best
time to get your relationships deeper
best time to begin to know your guys
better best time to be talking to you
guys better best time to get your
customer relationship better best time
for you to be talking to your employees
your teammates and circulating and how
you doing what's on your mind today I
was walking and strolling just to see if
everybody joking I'm just asking how you
doing how you doing how you doing how
you doing how you doing boom one of the
offices I walk in and person has a hands
on their face I say how you doing
and she's like can't even answer me I
said well how you doing everything good
she's in tears she was crying for two
minutes straight escena what here what's
on you might tell me we started talking
about so why don't you go for a walk
say you know what's exert a go break
just get out of here go for a walk and
just maybe take a break from news right
now for a couple hours because maybe you
need to do a media detox for yourself
and she just took the walk right and
then she came hey man thank you for that
sir no problem sometimes we need to be
doing that this is where you get your
relationships to go deeper this is the
time that you get your relationships to
be deeper because some people by the way
if you weren't getting your
relationships deeper while everything
was good
some of that stuff that's in your
control you're gonna pay a price for it
right now if you really don't have a
relationship with your partners vendors
employees sales people all that stuff
because it shows that you were having
strong relationship it's just it matters
today more than ever before number seven
there's a problem out of companies make
and that's accessibility I had a meeting
today with many of my staff members who
answer phones while we're going through
these times I talk to them about script
what to say what not to say how do we
finish calls how do we start calls what
if I'm being an [ __ ] to you when I'm
talking to you on the phone and I'm
somebody that's a customer or a vendor
or partner that's giving you a little
bit of a hard time how do you hand
that situation right now how do you make
sure you stay poised and I'm and I'm
broke playing this with one of our girls
that was answering phones and [ __ ] was
handling it so well but but this is the
time where you're sitting down talking
to you guys about accessibility people
gotta be able to get a hold of you
whether it's through online chat whether
it's the website chat text calls emails
doesn't matter you being accessible to
the right people right now matters more
than ever before
in times of crisis matters more than
ever before number eight research when a
crisis happens I like to do research
because again I'm affected by it if
you're a husband if you're a father if
you're a son if you're a brother if
you're friend if you're a leader if
you're a follower you ought to do
research because there's some formal
responsibilities there you have to the
people around you so what kind of
research do I do personal I go research
- I call experts three I want to get all
the data out there to see if I can find
any kind of trends that's what I want to
do with everything that I'm doing my
business pandemics economy market crash
it doesn't matter I do research number
nine speed back to equilibrium crisis I
got a little bull normal oh my gosh bone
the quicker you come up here the better
it is you could have a reaction like
this because you're not a machine old
robot but you got to come back to Cola
briam to make sure everything else is in
place it's a whole part of our poise
last but not least what needs to be
minimized what needs to be eliminated
and what needs to be increased simple
you know what let me experience this I
realized we have too much of this cut it
out we don't need it anymore
you know when we will experience is when
it would happen I just think we need to
lure we're doing that a little bit too
much and it's scaring people
lower it it's too much right now okay
great and you know what I realized we
needed this but we didn't have it why
don't we go get it and increase that a
little bit great minimize eliminate
increase what is it you need figured
that part out through crisis to see what
you can do to keep improving yourself as
a company so having said that there's a
couple things I told you I'm going to
share one of the videos I want you to
watch when I was in the military I
learned a lot of lessons half of them
was about how to deal on the crises in
chaos so if you've never watched this
video I I think it's titled 19 lessons I
learned in a military few haven't
watched a click on this to watch the
second thing I want you to do is many of
you know I've been working on this book
for the last three four years with Simon
& Schuster finally we get
to the end where it's gonna be sold all
over the place and I'll be announcing
the launch you pretty soon with some big
and exciting news so if you want to get
the details about the book that's coming
out that's all about strategy five keys
it's all about strategy it's about a 270
20 or 80 page book that I can't wait to
release you I'm actually very very
excited about this like a kid in a candy
store I want you to read it because I
know what what it can do to so many
people out there and I want the value
taemin audience to read this content so
if you want to be one of the first to
find out about the pre-launch that we'll
be making here soon I do text the word
five moves text the ward five moves to 3
1 0 3 4 0 1 1 3 2 again 5 moves 3 1 0 3
4 0 1 1 3 2 or if you're not in the
States go below in the description click
on a link and subscribe to the
newsletter to stay tuned when the book
launch is going to be coming out again I
can't wait for you to get your hands on
a book I'll be making some big
announcements on the book on the day of
pre-launch that'll be only to the people
that are part of our community having
said that if you haven't subscribed to
the channel please do so thanks for
watching everybody
take care bye bye
[Music]